Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking it.
Question,
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by Inc
tell and I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the four hour workweek.
I've been asked over and over again
how I choose to delegate tasks,
how I do 80 20 analysis and so on.
At the root of many of those
decisions is a simple question.
Actually two questions.
Number one,
how can I invest money to
improve my quality of life?
I use that in investing as well.
The second,
how can I spend a little money or moderate
money to save significant time inc
tell is one of those investments there
a turnkey solution for all of your
imaginable customer care needs.
I used Intel during the launch of
the four hour body, which was very,
very involved and they provided 24
seven customer service for my land rush
campaign because it was critical for
me to take care of every person who
purchased my books and participated.
This allowed me to focus on the things
that I am better. At my strengths,
like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for six months,
implementing that until
trains their experience,
customer service reps to
know your business and your
products inside and out and
make it your customers are raving fans.
They answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they
can do so across all platforms, including
email, phone, social media, texts,
even chat,
leaving your customers with poor
service or just mediocre service,
which by the way,
in a competitive pool is a huge liability.
Long wait times are unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business.
Uh,
Intel removes the logistics and
headaches of this type of communication,
allowing you to focus on your
strengths and grow your business.
It can be a real competitive advantage.
And I see many,
many ecommerce companies
and tech companies thinking
of customer service as a
good enough checkbox or an afterthought.
And it just like airbnb use design and
innovative ways to be a competitor and to
when you can do the same
thing with customer service.
So as a listener of this podcast,
you can get up to $10,000 off.
That's a big discount.
$10,000 off your startup fees and costs
by visiting [inaudible] dot com forward
slash. Tim, check it out. For more info,
go to [inaudible] Dot com I n k
a t e l.com forward slash. Tim,
this episode is brought
to you by legal zoom.
I have used legal zoom myself from any
of my businesses and many of the icons on
this podcast have actually
used legal zoom. For instance,
Matt Mullenweg of wordpress fame,
CEO of which is now worth more than a
billion dollars first incorporated his
company on legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that
more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses.
Whether that's setting up a will,
doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit or finding simple
cease and desist letter templates. Man,
do I use a lot of those? Uh,
legal zoom is not a law firm,
but they do have a network of independent
attorneys available in most states.
They can give you advice on
the best way to get started,
provide contract reviews and otherwise
help you run your business. And important.
There are no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency.
That means upfront pricing, customer
reviews, and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout Legal zoom.com today to see
how they can make life better and easier
for you and your business. If you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the Internet,
then you are asking for trouble.
Put together the safety nets,
get your t's crossed and your I's dotted.
Enter Promo Code Tim tim@legalzoom.com
to save 15% that's t I m for 15% off.
Check it out,
legal zoom.com
hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class
performers of all different types from
the worlds of business, military,
entertainment, athletics,
and sometimes combinations
of different fields,
and that is the case with this interview.
Of course,
the objective is to tease out
tactics, routines, habits,
specifics that you can use.
And my guest this time
around is by popular request,
Jason Khalifa,
that's k h a l Ipa.
You can say hello at Jason [inaudible]
on Instagram, Twitter, et cetera.
He is one of the fittest men in the world,
a title that was officially his when he
earned it at the crossfit games and won
the crossfit games in 2008 he is an
eight time crossfit games competitor,
a three time team USA crossfit member
and among other athletic feats.
He is dead,
lifted 550 lbs,
squatted 450 pounds and performed 64
pullups at a body weight of 210 pounds.
This podcast,
very important note of course you are
most likely listening to this as audio
only.
We have a bunch of video bonuses and
tutorials from Jason Recorded in my home
gym and elsewhere,
which you can find@youtube.com forward
slash timferriss two RS and two ss.
Keeping in mind that beyond sports,
Jason is also a very
successful entrepreneur.
He is the founder and CEO of NC fit,
which has more than 20 locations in
eight different cities and he is the co
founder of box to business,
which is a nonprofit that helps
Jim's become profitable businesses.
Jason uses the proceeds from box to
business to help fight pediatric cancer.
We cover a ton of stuff in this episode.
Lot of specifics,
a lot of stories including
his training in diet,
the hardest workouts he's ever performed,
the mentor who taught
him how to sell anything,
which is hilarious how he and his family
have coped with his daughters battle
with cancer. How he has navigated going
from competitive athlete. Two very,
very successful business owner and much,
much more so.
I hope you enjoy this
episode as much as I did.
Jason is a great guy and he is very,
very generous with sharing his knowledge
and don't forget to check out the
tutorial videos,
his favorite warmups,
et cetera@youtube.com
forward slash Tim Ferris.
Jason,
we'll do a quick sound check.
Could you please tell me
what you had for breakfast?
I had Kale smoothie and
an egg with Bacon on top.
One egg with Bacon on top.
One egg, a whole egg. Nope.
Cause I was on the road at 4:00 AM I went
to Starbucks and I took the sandwich.
I took it apart and I just had the
egg with the Bacon on top. Nice.
And then the Kale smoothie was before he
left the house. A Kale smoothie was, uh,
at the gym before I, yeah, shortly after.
What is in the Kale smoothie besides Kale,
Cale peanut butter. Um, some of this, uh,
projects, uh, like protein
powder and almond milk.
Fantastic.
Well,
I think we're just gonna keep rolling
since that sound check was so successful.
And while my pooch, Molly's gonna make
a racket thrown around an elk antler,
we're just going to get to it. So
welcome to the show and we'll be my look.
My living room. Thanks for
calling. It's great to be here.
And we just had some fun demoing
things and certainly learning things.
I wasn't doing anything I was
observing in the gym, in the garage.
So for people who are listening and want
some additional video, which I highly,
highly encourage,
just go to tim.blog/podcast and click on
this episode or you can go to youtube,
Tim Ferriss, two r's, two s's.
And you can find a bunch of video.
Now you are considered,
and I know you're not going to say this,
but a Demi God within the world
of crossfit by a lot of people,
people look up to you for good reason.
And I'm curious to know,
if you were to look back at
your peak competitive, uh,
success,
what do you think the advantages
were that you had or developed?
Like why were you as
successful as you were?
And of course you have
incredible work ethic and so on,
but if you, if you had to sort of dig
into that, what do you think the, the,
the elements were that made
you as successful as you were?
I think primarily it was that
I really enjoyed training.
I didn't do it, you know,
a lot of people,
they like to compete.
I didn't necessarily like to
computer or did like to compete.
I enjoyed competing,
but I enjoyed training more.
I like being in an environment that
just pushed me. I liked, I liked,
I'm getting comfortable,
uncomfortable.
I liked leaving the gym and feeling
like I just got my buck kicks.
It made me feel good
about what I accomplished.
And then I went on and try to accomplish
that same concept in the rest of my
life.
Right.
And I think that was something I really
picked up on early on when I first found
crossfit back in 2006 and then I won
the crossfit Games in Oh eight and I was
able to compete eight more times, mainly
because I just love to train, you know,
and,
and the byproduct or the expression of
that was my ability to go out there and
compete.
Are there any particular workouts
that come to mind or exercises?
Anything that you find
particularly enjoyable,
even though they might be very painful?
I mean, I, I liked the ones that give
you the biggest return, right? I mean,
I think if you're doing thrusters,
yes, they're very challenging,
but they give you a huge
return in terms of benefit,
in terms of the way you look in terms
of whether you feel the byproduct of
strengths. I think thrusters,
burpees, those type things.
If I had to pick several
items I would only do,
or several movements I'm wanting
to do for the rest of my life,
it'd be things like that.
[inaudible]
if we were to say, look, while we're
going to look forward in a second,
I want to keep focusing on that
for a moment. Any particular, uh,
if you wanted to gage, say
the, the fitness right,
they cross fitness of
anyone for that matter.
Are there any particular tests that you
would put them through to evaluate that?
Whether it's like a certain variation
of Fran or anything like that?
I would just look at like different
metrics. I look at, you know,
what is your mile time? Uh, how
many pull ups can you complete? Uh,
what is your Max deadlift,
back squat press, um, and
then start looking at a few,
like the movements that combine both.
Right.
And so I think sometimes there's people
that are really good at running and
there's some people that are
really good at, um, lifting.
But I think the beauty is when he can
combine those two. And so you know,
a lot of like the Franz and
the different types of work.
I like a fight gone bad score. Those are
good ways. And what is a fight going bad?
So Phicom vow was originally created
a with Bj Penn and Greg Glassman.
Oh yeah. Long time ago.
And baseball was, was,
this was back when Bj was probably
training at the Health Gracie Academy in
mountain view old school long time ago.
And essentially what it is is one minute,
one minute, one minute,
five, five movements,
and then you one minute rest
and do that for three rounds.
What are the five movements? So it's a
Sumit old high pole. There's a push press,
there's a rower,
a wall ball and a box jump and all the
movements are light enough that you can
keep moving on them. And so you know,
when Bj finished the, as the story goes,
when Bj finished it was like, aw
man, I feel like a fight gone bad.
And so that's kind of how the story goes.
Just as a random side note,
I used to go to these chiropractors,
the Jansens who worked on a lot of
fighters and I remember they described Bj
Penn's hip flexors as the
hip flexors of a camel.
They said they were just like a
quadricep done normal humans. Just, uh,
if you were to say want to get someone
hooked on exercising because you enjoyed
the training, not everyone
enjoys training. So let's
say you're taking someone,
you want to get them hooked
on that drug of training. Uh,
is there any particular approach
that you would take? I mean,
you've coached lot of people,
you've,
I'm sure encountered every different
type of person from NFL player to say
engineer who's never played sports
and everybody in between. Uh,
what do you do to get someone hooked so
that they continue to come to the gym?
Yes. I mean, I've been really
fortunate, you know, over the years. Um,
I started a company NC fit and we have
a ton of members and I've been able to
look at it and say, hey, what is generally
gets them to kind of stay with us?
And more times than not, it's starting
off slow and then working their way up.
I think a lot of people get Gung Ho,
right? They come in, Oh, you know,
I want to lose weight.
I want to do this one or that.
I'll eat whatever you tell me,
I'll do whatever you told me.
And then all of a sudden a
month later they're gone. Right?
So I think the secret to success is, hey,
just take your time, right? This is not a,
this is, this is a
lifelong journey, right?
It's not like a one month you
don't fad. It's, you know,
I want to be fit and I want to
be fit for the rest of my life.
And so I think it's important to recognize
that and it makes small steps towards
the right direction. You
know, take out sugar, do this,
do that small little steps,
then go into the gym and
start doing certain stuff.
But I think finding a comradery,
finding a coach,
and find a community support you.
Our rule number one,
I think that doing it on your own
is very challenging. You know,
you and I were talking about cooking
earlier and it's like if I want to learn
how to cook, really, really learn how
to cook, I could learn from a book,
I could learn from maybe watching a show,
but to really kind of
dive into the nuances,
I would need to have someone to kind of
show me in the kitchen what I would do
next. At least for me. Right. I
don't have enough experience with it.
And some people going to the gym, sure
they can read books, you can do stuff.
But I think having someone there,
like a coach advise them
on different things is,
is is going to be an easy way for
them to get more success from it.
Yeah. I think the, just to reiterate that,
I think the social accountability
piece is huge. So having some type of,
of social cohesion just gigantic.
And for people who are listening
who might be in the sticks,
don't think you have access to that.
You can certainly find communities online
like coach.me and other, uh, other,
other sites or services along those lines.
But the,
the point you made also that I think is
really important to underscore is in the
beginning,
focusing on the good program that you
will follow versus the perfect program
that you'll fit that you'll quit. Because
a lot of people come in, like you said,
they're like, okay, I haven't
done anything since college.
Now I'm going to do a two hour workout
five times a week as my new year's
resolution. And they just flame out or
they get injured or fill in the blank.
And like you said, they're gone a few
weeks later as opposed to saying, look,
since you're starting from zero,
let's just do whatever it might be,
half hour workout twice a week so that
you develop the habit and then you can
always make it harder,
more complex later. But if you make it
too hard, too complex in the beginning,
you're going to be gone.
Yeah.
Like we have a program that
we've incorporated calls
the rise program and what
it incorporates, the nutritionist, a
mindset coach and I, and a fitness coach.
And for a lot of people, it's all a
mindset, right? It's all for decades.
They haven't exercise, they've use food
as an outlet or whatever it may be. Right?
And that's okay,
but they need to get over that in their
head to truly make an impact and change
for, for a long time. Right.
Instead is making it like the short term
thing that you really get down to the
root of the problem and make it as more
of a part of their daily routine instead
of just something they do.
Right. And that starts,
but to start it slowly then work it up
is much easier than just to kind of go
crazy. And then it just, I
haven't seen it work as well.
And then I have a nuclear meltdown and
have to restart again for your next new
year's resolution. That's right. Uh,
I'm going to take a couple of
questions here that have been, uh,
volleyed over via the Internet because
there's some really good ones and they
range from training to
family, to business. Uh,
so we're going to get to that in a
second, but I wanted to ask you, uh,
you mentioned NC fit.
How many locations do you currently have?
24,
24 locations.
So you've been very successful as an
athlete and many people who put in the
effort and focus that you did.
And athletics are so singularly
focused that they have trouble.
And I've observed this and friends
transferring them to a career outside of
competitor, rent sponsored athlete. Uh,
if you were sitting down with
an accomplished athlete or not,
who wanted to say,
uh,
get into business and let's
just for the sake of simplicity,
say it's a similar business
there somewhere in the
Midwest and they want to get
into fitness and gyms and so on.
What advice would you give them or
resources would you point them to, uh,
to increase the likelihood of success?
Yeah, I mean, one of the things I'd ask
them, and I could ask this often is,
you know, hey, I want to open up a
gym. What do you think? I'm like, okay,
well let's start with these three
simple questions, right? Number one,
are you qualified to do so?
Right?
What makes you qualified
to open up this business?
Do you have an expertise in it?
Do you how?
How are you going to
basically give yourself this
competitive advantage that you
know that when you go to open up,
you're going to win, right? Right.
What is your competitive, what's
the credibility, right? Yeah.
Just because you like to work out,
does it mean you should necessarily go
open up a gym? I love to eat, I love food,
but I sure as hell are not going to
open up a restaurant because I'm not
qualified to do so. I don't have
the training, the expertise. Right,
and it's okay if you
don't in certain areas,
just go find an expert in those other
areas right there and ask of you is,
you know the, are you doing it with a
strong intention is strong. Why? Right?
Like what is your why? Why do you want to
open this business? Is it to make money?
Because if it's just to make money,
just like competing at the crossfit games,
you didn't have a strong internal why?
Because when your back's up against
the wall, it's very challenging.
You need to revert back to that.
Why?
To push through and in business
it's not always, you know,
rainbows and Unicorns,
right?
There's challenging times and senior to
be able to revert back to your internal
why of why you started to be able
to do well. So I would say, hey,
how are you going to win? Right?
Tell me how you're going to win. Why?
Why are you better than the other guy
down the street to do you have a strong
reason why you want to open it?
And then three,
is it a good time in
your life to do it right?
Is it a good time for you to open
it? Do you just have a baby? Um,
do you have tons of mortgages in
different types of stuff, right?
Or is it a good time in your
life to go ahead and, you know,
go open up this business is
really what I like to ask people.
What are the most common mistakes that
you see or that you think you avoided?
Like if you look back at your business,
another way to phrase it so you can tackle
it however you want is what were some
of the most important decisions
that you made? Looking back,
I think looking back,
it was understanding that back in the
day you weren't going to make money off
your competitive fitness career.
And so I had to open up a business and
I had to open it and I think one of the
best things I ever did was I recognize it,
try and rob and steal as much as I can,
knowledge from people around me.
So when I was in high school, I worked
at the front desk at a conventional gym.
Then when I graduated high school,
I went to college,
I started working as a sales associate
there and I started making good money.
So as I'm going to a junior college,
you went to vast valley. Actually.
I was there and I, I just got woken
up like no one cares about me.
I was like the jock and I was like the,
you know,
kind of like the class
clown in high school,
they'll have a sudden you get to college.
It's like they don't care about you.
Right? So I really turned a
corner. I say, hey look, you know,
I need to take responsibility
for what I need to get done.
I want to be successful. And so I
started going to school full time,
working full time mode. I also did
was I learned how to talk to people.
I learned how to sell,
which was really important because in
my line of work in the fitness industry,
your coach and you're, you're talking
to people, you're coaching him.
But if you're a business owner,
you also need to learn how to sell.
But one of the things I would
also do is on the, you know, dot.
Twice a week I would go and ride the
elliptical with the owner of the business
and I would just pick his brain,
understand what's going on.
I think one of those things early on
was recognizing how wanting to learn
everything I could from his mistakes.
I didn't make as many.
And one of the things that we've done
a lot is delegate out things, right.
Not, you know, have enough of a
humbleness to be like, hey look,
I can't do everything best the
best I need to hire outside people.
And I think I learned that early on
from him learning from him some of his
mistakes. How did you convince
him to do the elliptical with you?
What was the pitch,
right? You were in sales.
So how did you get the owner to hang
out with the former class clown on the
elliptical? So funny enough he really took
me on as like a mentor. He really like,
he really mentored me really well and
he would ride the elliptical as part of
his fitness routine routine.
And I would just go over there
and it just go meet with him.
And I don't think he disliked it because
we would just, you know, bullshit.
Have good conversation.
I think it kind of made the time
go by a little bit quicker. Got It.
So you just roll up when he was working
at [inaudible] rolling. And, uh,
when your back is against the wall,
you mentioned the why.
So when you were competing and say,
this is actually a question that
came up at least once from, uh,
people who are listening to the podcast.
One wanted me to ask you what,
why did you go back to when
you were competing in the
games? I mean at the time,
right? Or, or
uh,
sorry to keep rephrasing my questions,
but I've had too much
caffeine and that is uh,
when you were say behind or you
saw someone gaining on you, uh,
the why or like what is the self talk
to make sure that you don't fall out of
that you don't drop the ball or otherwise
just get, get psyched out. Well,
I think positive self talk is
a really hard thing to learn,
but it's an important trait to
develop. And I've learned that, um,
over the years with a mindset
coach I work with where, you know,
you try and find ways to reframe things
in your head if something's going wrong,
instead of saying, oh,
my legs hurt, you say,
hey folks on mid foot strike if
you're running or whatever. Right?
You try and rephrase it in a positive
and reverting back to your why.
I think it's really important
that going into these games,
what I would do is I would tell myself
that I've made a commitment to myself,
my family,
to go out there and do this.
And I wanted to do it because I wanted to
get comfortable with the uncomfortable.
I wanted to see where I stack up against
my competitors and I wanted to do it
for me. Right? And at the time I
didn't have as many other obligations.
Now as life changes, right? Things
change. But at the time, my why was, hey,
I made a commitment.
I'm gonna do this.
And I remember one year we did
this camp Pendleton race and I was,
it's a 10 mile, just crazy Hilron and I
was like, halfway done. I just, you know,
I'm like going through like this desert
and I look around, there's no one around.
I'm just like,
oh gosh,
and I see a translates to the
true story just walking across.
I'm just looking at him like, what
the hell or a biggest spider? Maybe.
It was interesting. It was big ass. I
was like, well, what am I doing out here?
Right? And I had an instantly revert
back of my head. You know what?
I made a commitment. That commitment was
I was going to finish out these games,
so I bet her slap myself in the face,
stop being a wimp and finish it.
Because if I allowed myself to give in
and then what other things would I allow
myself to give into?
Right?
I made a commitment to myself and
I wanted to live up to that. Now,
over the years, because of other
things happened in my life,
I haven't been able to make
that strong of commitment.
So therefore I choose not even to go
out there and, and, and, and attempt
and the,
I'm very fascinated by these
little moments or days or weeks.
It can really affect the complete
trajectory of people's lives.
And you mentioned a couple of minutes ago,
you get to college age,
you realize all right and no longer the
class clown in high school and you did a
course correct, right? You
started going to school full time.
So what triggered that?
Was it a particular conversation?
Was it a particular afternoon?
What was it? So, you know,
so
going out of high school,
I thought it was gonna play football at,
ended up not working out. So I ended
up going to West Valley and you know,
first day it wasn't that big
of a deal. Right. I get it.
I get there the first day I'm like, Oh,
I'm not West Valley and no big deal.
I'll transfer another
school in a couple of years.
But all my friends had gone to a
four year Santa Claire University,
which is where I ended up graduating from.
Right.
But I just remember first day of school,
we're going round and we're all saying
our names, right? And it's like, Hey,
I'm John, this is my first, second
year. Hey, I'm Mary, this is my,
you know,
whatever second semester it is.
And then all of a sudden you have this
woman next to me and I kid you not write
my first class on my first day
at West Valley and lady goes, hi,
my name is uh, Suzanne. I can't remember
the name exactly. She has that for a fact.
This is my seventh year at West Valley.
And I just remember looking at her and
looking at this teacher and just be like,
dude, I gotta get my ass in check and
you'd get my shit together. Right.
That's what I told myself. Right.
And so that moment I left there,
I went to the counselor's
opposite, said, hey, look,
I need to figure out the best way
to get the heck out of this school.
And so I ended up on taking full
class loads, do whenever I had to do.
I ended up applying to Santa Clara two
times after that and not being accepted
because I tried after one year,
I didn't get accepted.
I tried for like a year and
a half getting to accepted.
Then after two years I was accepted,
which got me on track to graduate in four.
So I graduated with all my peers, which
was great. I graduated my wife actually,
which was really cool.
Um,
but that was the moment that really
like kinda sparked it. Like, dude,
like playtime's over high school's
done. It's, you're in the wheel rolled.
No one really cares about you.
You better get your ass in check.
And when you applied, make me think of
Rudy a little bit. So you get, he applied,
didn't get in, applied, didn't
get in and applied and got in.
What did you change in between the not
getting accepted and getting accepted?
Well Matt had more courses
underneath my belt. Swag.
They didn't have to use my
high school GPA anymore. Right.
You're able to only you they call it,
you could use your trend,
your credits that would transfer.
That's right. Got It. All right, so,
so many questions,
but I'm going to pull some in from
the audiences from fern Hernandez.
What are your thoughts on the frequency
of doing crossfit as another way?
What benefits do you lose or gain from
doing say twice a week versus four to
five times a week?
I mean,
I think by design,
when you look at it like a program and
if it's constantly varied by design,
he should be able to do it, you know,
five days a week and you should be okay.
If the programming is an appropriate in
the volume is good and you're listening
to your body, you should be able
to perform that program, you know,
five days a week because of the variance,
right?
You should be able to go long
one day heavy one day, you know,
below parallel one day.
And that just depends on how much effort
people put into the program itself.
So two days is better than no days,
but two days also
challenging cause you go in,
you get really sore and then you're,
you recover it and you get really sore
again and your body never gets into this
rhythm. So assuming you go
to a gym as good programming,
I think you can go five days a week.
And you and I were also though,
just to touch on good programming in
the gym when we were messing around,
messing around,
you were demonstrating backs while we're
talking about a five by five and so on
these five,
five sets of five reps and so on.
If the variance doesn't exist and
someone's trying to do five by five,
seven times a week with the squad.
Yeah, I mean you got, you got to have a
program that has variants, right? So we,
we do it at our gym and he's going to
have one person creates this template,
the skeleton,
and then he creates the workouts and
then we have a peer reviewed by six other
of our coaches and then
it gets back to him.
So we try to have a lot of and balances
our program because regardless of who's
programming the program,
there's always going to be some type of
bias towards what you like. Sure. Yeah,
always. And so you need to have other
people have checks and balances on that.
How might someone create
a skeleton of a program?
And I'm not saying just Joe blow in the
street. I'm saying one of your coaches,
right?
W what does that process look like?
What are they thinking about or
considering as they do it? Well,
and I think they're looking
at time domains, right? So
you're looking at, you know,
are we talking five minutes? We talk
in 12 and as we talk in 20 minutes,
we're talking in 30 or 40 minute
long workouts, total duration,
total duration of the actual, you know,
rap email, whatever they're doing, right?
Things are look just for non crossfit
is as many rounds or reps as possible.
And then you know, you start talking
about in the skill work, right?
What is a theme for the month that
we tie in to develop someone's hand,
Stan and we tried to, there's a lot
of things in play. It's, it's, it's a,
it's a challenging topic
to discuss briefly,
but in theory it's hey, let's have
a, let's have some big macro goal,
right? Maybe it's to get everybody
ready for a five kids coming up.
Maybe it's to get this skill of maybe
we start noticing that our gym members
need benefit in x. Let's create that
macro goal. And then during our warm ups,
make sure we touch base on
it several times a week.
Then let's have these other goals where
it's like we go heavy to three times a
week, right? Then we go longer.
Metcons are metabolic conditioning
workouts couple times a week,
and we add any short burst,
high intensity, one's a
couple times a week. So in,
in skeleton you want to think about,
you want to push you on to pull you
on a squat once a week, right? Um,
you want to incorporate the Olympic
lifts as you know, when you can.
And that's kind of the big picture
stuff. But you also, when you program,
you want to think about kind
of this idea of, you know,
if I'm programming workout,
I want to think about what's
going to keep people moving.
So you wouldn't want to do, for
example, uh, squats, lunges,
jumping here, squads, uh,
jumping lunges and what it was
like a bunch of whatever he's,
what'll end up happening is people will
just burn out their legs and let us sit
there and stand there until they can
recover. But now if you did, you know,
jumping lunges followed by
pushups, they're not the
same muscle Muslims, right?
They're different functions.
And so you can keep your body moving.
And as you mentioned, uh, when we were
chatting before recording just the audio,
the Olympic lifts generally would
come after say a familiarity,
at least familiarity,
maybe a mastery of the mechanics of say,
power lifting movements and
some gymnastic components. Well,
I think we incorporate the
Olympic lifts early on. We do.
How do you do that safely?
I think it ultimately just comes down
to the coaches that are doing it right.
How do you,
you start off,
you make sure that people can do it right
with just the PVC pipe or a light bar
and then you can work your way up.
But I think the difference is
that whereas with the power lifts,
it doesn't take as long to develop the,
all the techniques incorporated with it.
With the Olympic lifts it does.
And so you need to be okay with doing
the Olympic lifts early on, right?
Almost from the beginning.
It's okay,
but you need to do them at a moderate
controlled level verse the back's way.
You can kind of push a little bit more.
I mean, you could push them all be,
don't want to push the
Olympic lifts so much.
So the start developing bad habits and
the same thing applies to the backwash is
a little bit less. So the Olympic lifts a
little bit easier to Incor uh, you know,
they're, they're highly technical. Sure.
Let's just say you have average person
off the street or powerlifter comes in.
I want to learn Olympic weightlifting if
they have really bad thoracic mobility
and shoulder extension. Right?
So they're, they're here, right?
They can barely get there.
Their biceps past there.
They're yours. Do you have any,
any favorite approaches to helping address
that or, or any suggestions? You know,
our friend Kelly has some good
tools. Mobilitywod Riley start. Yeah.
Kelly's threat.
I mean,
I think that there's multiple different
things you could do but ultimately
needed commit to it, right? I mean,
if you have poor, uh, you know,
shoulder range of motion, it's going
to take you out to develop that.
And you know, that doesn't mean you
have to avoid all lifts all together,
still doing them. Just recognize you need
to put in the time, you know a couple,
you know, 10 20 minutes a day to develop
the range of motion and mobility.
And the best way to do that
is by incorporating the
movements slow and control
with light to little note no weight,
right?
If you want to really
develop a good squat,
try and work on the squat up against
the wall with no weight and work through
the full range of motion of it up against
the wall. You mean facing the wall?
Yeah.
Question from Luke Campbell,
ask about his training with
former endurance athlete.
Now coach Chris Henshaw's.
It was interesting to hear how a giant
like Jason could build his aerobic
capacity without sacrificing size or
strength. How does he do it specifically?
That's a great question. Um, you
know, Hinshaw is great. You know,
years ago I started looking at summary
results from across the games and it
would be like, you know, top 10 top 10 top
10 top 10 50th you know, top 10 top 10.
I'd be like, Oh boy, I got
a glaring weakness there.
And so I found Chris and he really helped
me out and he made running fun for me.
He made running. Who is who? Who
is Chris? Just for [inaudible].
He's a local guy raise here out of
Palo Alto area yet. And he's a former,
you know, iron man triathlete.
Really successful but he,
but he has a unique way of making
running quantifiable and fun.
And what I mean by that is,
you know,
I'll go to the track and before I'd
just be like, oh run 400 meters.
I would just like run it aimlessly. But
it felt good for him to give me, you know,
a hundred meter pace goals, 200
meter pays goals, et cetera.
And then those goals then
turn into something I could
really try and shoot for.
And I think going back to the whole thing
about someone going to the gym is for
those people who are interested
in doing running or doing types,
does having a program that kind of gives
you quantifiable numbers is shoot for,
I believe it's a great way,
not only to get better results
but also to keep it more fun.
You don't need this go out for a five
k on your own. That's cool. I get it.
But you should start quantifying
what you're targeting,
the numbers are and your target paces.
And that's what I did with him and
that's why I was able to maintain those
numbers.
When you were at your peak of of training,
what did your nutrition look like and
were there any goto supplements on top of
that?
It's a tricky sort of murky waters that
we get into sometimes and it's fine if,
if any of them were sponsors, but if you
could just indicate which, which were,
if that's the case,
but a diet.
So would your nutrition look like in
at the height of training and then any
particular supplements that
were kind of your go to?
So I never have and I until this day
eat as much as what most people probably
think I eat. Um, but with the amount
of his training, sometimes, you know,
just Broccoli and cauliflower weren't
cutting it for the carbohydrates I need to
do retain. So sweet potatoes had to
be thrown in and things like that.
I try to eat real food, right? I still do,
I try and eat real food and I try
and avoid excess amounts of sugar and
different types of things.
But that doesn't mean that if my
daughter wants to go out and you know,
if it's her birthday,
I'm not going to eat her birthday.
Kicking it and never has meant
that. Right. I'm okay with that.
I trained because at times I want to be
able to go and in and enjoy a, you know,
a Margarita with my wife.
Right. That's okay. And it
always has been that same way,
whether I've been training at the
highest level or, or where I'm at today.
And you know, as far as recovery and I
partnered with a company called progenics.
I think they make a good
recovery tool for me.
That's something I use outside of
that. Maybe some fish oil and, and,
and that's pretty much the extent
of it, right? It's just real food.
I think people don't realize the value
you can get from just consuming real
regular food.
And did you track macros
and all that type of stuff?
Just know a lot of the guys at the
top don't really track all the macros.
Some of them do, but not, not
a lot of the guys, you know,
a lot of them just work hard,
train hard and just eat appropriately.
All right. This is, this is
a question that I would love
to hear your thoughts on.
This is from Lee Jackson.
What do you picture your workout
to be when you hit 60 years of age?
That is, I mean I think my workout is
gonna be roughly the way it is right now.
Just just basically scaled
down. Meaning you know, the,
the demands that I have at, you know,
my age with, you know, my street.
Like we all need a squall, we only
oppressed. We only lift. So what are,
I'm 60 30 50 I still want to
be doing those same movements.
I just might do it a little
bit of a less intensity. Right.
And even now being 31 the intensity
that can bring the workouts a little bit
different than when I was 25 my body's
been beat up a lot by doing that and so I
just need to recognize it, listen to
my body and recover as well as I can.
But the amount of volume I'm putting
in isn't as much as it used to be.
And I assume the time I'm 60 the
amount of volume I'm putting,
it wouldn't be as much,
but the movements would be similar.
Is there any particular type of movement,
a conditioning strength,
fill in the blank that you'd really
like to work on and develop more now?
In other words, you talked about
like top 10 top 10 top 10 50th place,
top 10 the top 10 are there any particular
weaknesses that you're trying to work
on now? It doesn't have to
be limited to the gym either.
Like is there anything that you're there
they're working on currently? I mean,
obviously, you know, I
like rolling Jujitsu.
There's a ton of things
get better at there.
But for me it's really on the business
side, on the family side, right?
I'm trying to be the best dad I can be
the best husband I can be and I'm trying
to support our business [inaudible] and
run it the best way possible and treat
people that way. And that's what
I'm really focused on. You know,
stealing a line from Mark Cuban is just
the sport of business and I'm trying to
win at that right now
for myself in particular.
So that's what I'm focused on my fitness
side, I'm still hitting it all the time.
Right?
I still work out really hard,
but don't have any specific goals
other than just to maintain my fitness.
So this is,
this is actually a segue there.
We're talking about family
a little bit and uh,
these were very highly uploaded.
So this,
this is a question from Sherry Gall.
I've so admired him as an
athlete and businessmen,
his work ethic and determination
to continue to improve,
as well as his humility of pushed
him to great levels of success.
I've also watched his journey through
Ava's illness and seem him give back in
the midst of it, blood drives, etc. I know
behind all of this is a good marriage.
I'd like him to talk about
marriage and how ava is doing.
I would also be fun to hear his
perspective on the evolution of the sport,
but let's,
let's keep that separate.
Could you talk a little bit just about
the components of a good marriage and
also just tell us a little bit about
your, about your family and, and Ava.
A lot of people listening are going to be
familiar. Sure. Yeah. So my wife and I,
Ashley, we started dating
freshman year of high school,
so 1415 years old.
And we've been together almost ever since.
What happened is we started dating
for a week, two weeks. Actually,
I thought we were in love, right? I went
home. I told her mom, I'm like, mom,
I found a woman I'm gonna
marry. Right. And I was all
fired up. And then of course,
two weeks later she dumps me
cause she said I was too nice.
Well, you know, a year
later, right. She knew,
she knew, you know, we
are meant to be together.
So we ended up getting back
together again a year later.
We haven't been separated since. Right. So
that was, you know, 15, 16 years old. And,
um, so, you know, we went to college,
Graduate College together, did our thing.
We got married in 2009, uh,
had our first child in 2011,
Ava. And then we had our second
child. She has a 14. Kayden. Uh,
ava was diagnosed with
Leukemia January 21st, uh,
2016.
So about a little over a year ago.
And uh,
you know,
I think when you talk about what makes
a marriage successful, I think it,
it's an obviously a number of things.
You have to respect each other.
You have to become best friends.
You need to be able to be okay with
supporting each other on their journeys,
but you also need to, um,
align well on difficult times.
And I didn't know that until ava got sick.
You know, when you're in high school,
you don't know how your wife is going
to react or girlfriend is going to react
to a negative situation life.
And I think what's really intriguing
about what happened to us is my wife and I
and my family in general has gotten
a lot closer through Ava's diagnosis
primarily because she was so strong
and she still is. And that's the,
that's really exciting for me because
I take on like, Hey, you know,
we're going to get after this,
we're going to be successful.
And she was the one who
really started that from the
beginning. You know, when we,
we first find out ava
had a leukemia, we, uh,
we were called the Er at Stanford Er.
Before that she was having a lot of
leg pain in different types of things.
It was, when did that start? How old was
she? Uh, so she, she right now she's five,
she'll be six in a month. You know,
it's, look, looking back on it now,
it probably, we probably have
identified the shit leukemia earlier,
but everything like had a reason
like sure shedding your infection.
Then she had another one, then she
had another one and then you know,
the doctors are just the
worst ear infection I've
ever seen. We were like, wow,
well her immune system
seems kind of suppressed.
Like we didn't really think
about it. We're just like, oh,
we'll just keep getting her medicine.
She has an ear infection. Then it's like,
oh my legs really hurt. I can't walk more
than a hundred feet without stopping.
Oh man, it must be growing beans. Let's
get you a trampoline was get you in a PT,
all these different things.
Then she started having bruising and
that's where we knew something was up and
so we're waiting for blood work.
We called it in the Er and when they
told us that night that she had leukemia,
he was at like 2:00 AM in the morning
and I should remember, you know,
as he was a,
it was a very challenging time for us.
And now I've had a lot of time to reflect
on it, so I'm a little less, you know,
uh,
you know,
I used to talk about it as a lot harder
now that I've reflected on a lot,
it's a little bit easier to talk about,
but I just remember when I told my wife,
you know, she just went out,
you know, we're, you know,
I was crying and she just looks at me.
She's like, hey look, you tell our family,
uh, you know, tell her family,
let them know she has leukemia,
but just tell them that they want to cry.
They can crowd outside.
But as soon as he walked in the doors,
they'd better be happy and they better
have a smile on their face or I'll stay,
can't be let it. Right. And it was kind
of that mentality that was just like,
you know, Kinda like, you know,
she's just like, yeah, hell yeah,
we're going to crush this shit. And
then it made me realize like, oh yeah,
we're going to crush it. Like it was
this very much so like football, like,
you know,
you're in the huddle and like you're in
the fight of your life and it's like, no,
no, we're going to
crush this thing. Right.
And we've had that mentality ever since.
And you know, her strength has been,
has been awesome to see from a
marriage perspective. Right. So that's,
that's a kind of a cool, cool thing to
find out about your spouse for sure.
What types of practices or routines,
anything really,
uh,
do you have that helps the family
to be as cohesive as possible?
Well, I think we have a lot
of really good family support.
So we've been super blessed. You know,
the night that my daughter was diagnosed,
my mom and dad took my son
and took him for a month.
We were in the hospital for five
weeks. Right. Um, Lucille Packard,
they've done some really great things
for us. Um, but you know, like when,
when you see that family around and then
all of a sudden my father in law would
be there every day my phone, I would just
be sitting in the waiting room, right?
We didn't, we wouldn't call them when
doing it. You'd just be sitting there.
And that family dynamic has been something
that's been really special to see.
And, uh, it's something that will
never, I'll never forget. And even now,
here we are over a year later and we
still have a lot of challenging times and
it's a family that helps us get through
all of it, right? Because my, for example,
on Saturday, we were in Vegas, my mom
and dad helped watch our children set,
my wife and I could go have
a night out to ourselves.
And those are really important things
in life to my wife and I since the
beginning, I've always said, hey,
look, it's, we love our children,
but it's me and you first
for our relationships. If
our relationship isn't good,
then we're not gonna be able to
have a solid home for our children.
And so we've really tried to set aside
time to do date nights and do this and do
that,
which has really been helpful,
especially during this time because
sometimes we have to have adult
conversations.
Like right after this I'm going to
go see a counselor because you know,
we need to get some support to help us
with this situation in my wife Ad have
adult conversation about that
to go see a counselor. Yeah.
If you were giving advice to someone who,
for instance just found out
their child is diagnosed with x,
some type of very intimidating disease
and they wanted any thoughts or advice
from you whatsoever, like for
instance, what your wife said,
which was you can cry but has to be
outside once you come in yet you have to
have a smile on your face as it is there.
Is there anything else that you
wish that you'd share with them?
I think it's really important
to educate yourself,
educate yourself on the disease.
So my daughter has all,
it's a specific type of leukemia. Uh,
she's, uh, it's, it's a very treatable,
which is awesome, right? There's a
lot of them that aren't as treatable.
And my heart goes out to his families.
I mean,
you come sit in the oncology department
for a day with me and you'll just be
humbled. So what I would say
to them is educate yourself.
We've had phenomenal health care,
phenomenal.
But there's been one or two times where
we've had to catch the doctors because
sometimes, you know, they have other
things going on. But for me, there's no,
there's nothing else going on.
It's just this.
But I need to be able to educate myself
on it with all the different medications.
What's going on here?
What is this one of the side effects?
What should we be looking for?
Because those things are critical,
especially for us.
I mean,
we ended up in the ER probably once
every two weeks because of, um, uh, uh,
temperatures. But we have to be actively
engaged to take the temperature.
We had to be actively engaged on what the
side effects are of certain medicines.
I think that's the most critical pieces.
Educate yourself on what's going on
cause no one's going to care more than
you're going to care. This is going
to seem maybe like a gear shift,
but I think it could be related.
When we were talking about transfer,
when we're in the gym earlier looking
at say modeling your pushup position so
that it transfers to other movements.
Your elbows are flaring out,
looking at deadlifting say first and
foremost and a conventional stance that it
transfers more to and everything else.
You mentioned Amref
earlier the as many reps,
as many rounds as possible and you
mentioned an rep philosophy before I hit
record and I was like, okay, I want to
come back to that. So what does that,
what does that mean?
Does it apply to areas outside of the gym?
So it's actually something
I've been working on for a
while and I've given talks
about is called the Amorette mentality.
And to me it's the way that, you know,
I kind of live my life and
I'm trying to live my life.
And with the emirate mentality really
means is think about if someone said you,
Hey, I want you to do as
many pushups as you can in,
in a minute while you're doing and
you're just focused on that right now.
Focus on anything else.
She's folks on the pushups.
And then when you're done with that, you
move on right now on podcasts with you.
This one focused on, on, um,
am rapping with you right now.
We're trying to do the
best we can together,
but what I'm not doing is on my phone.
Right?
And talking to you and trying to
work out at the same time. Right?
I'm not doing that because, you know, I
think nowadays I would make the argument,
I don't know if we're less productive
or more productive than we were 20 years
ago because 20 years ago when you're at
work, you're working, when you're at home,
you're at home.
Now it's this huge carryover.
So what I found myself
doing for many years,
and I had to really knit
myself in the button,
I still am trying to get a lot better
is I wouldn't be focused on my family,
are focused on what I was doing,
I'd be focusing on are things,
there's times where I would go to dinner
and I would be having dinner with my
wife and I wouldn't remember anything we
talked about cause I would be thinking
about the crossfit competition
I had coming up. Right.
And that was an example of [inaudible]
am happy not being present and focused on
what I was doing. So the theory
is you identify your focus, right?
Whatever it may be, you know, for
me it's family fitness business,
then you work hard at it,
right? Whatever it may be.
Then you switch gears and you do this
throughout your day and then every now and
then you need to reevaluate.
So I'll give you an example.
For a while I was going competing
at the highest level in crossfit,
owning the business. And I had the
family that I had more children in.
The business grew and the
competition got harder.
So I decided to switch gears and go team
because I didn't have as much time to
allocate to these other things.
So I had to switch gears,
evaluate what was really important to me,
and then do that.
But then when my daughter got sick,
it was another time for me to reevaluate
what am I trying to really focus on and
how many things can I actually am rap.
So now I chose not to compete because I
want to do the best I can in business.
Then I want to switch gears and go best
I can with family and then I still want
to work out,
but I can't spend as much time on it.
And that's kind of the Amorite
mentalities. Identify her focus,
work hard at it and switch gears and then
every now and then reevaluate and get
rid of some of the stuff on your plate.
And when you're, when you're reevaluating,
do you sit down with a pad
and a pen and write it out?
Do you see,
do you have a set time when you might
do that in the morning or at night?
If you could just describe perhaps some
of the details of what that looks like.
I mean,
reevaluating happens with big moments in
your life such as your daughter getting
sick or you're getting
married or you have children,
you have reevaluate with
the things you're going on.
You used to love maybe playing
video games for three hours a day.
Once you have a kidney reevaluate,
you can't do it anymore, right? You,
you just can't, it, you need
to reevaluate those times.
And so reevaluation happens kind of
internally for me. Uh, whether, um,
you know, uh, on the bike,
just kind of like, you know,
thinking in my thoughts or
whatever it may be. But I, I,
I identify every so
often when I reevaluate,
but on a consistent daily basis, I try
and check in with myself. I trust myself,
hey, did I do the best job
today as I could to be a father,
to be a husband, to be a business
owner and did I maintain my fitness?
Did I do that today? And if the
answer is yes, fuck hell yeah,
but if the answer's no, then
there's always tomorrow. Right? And,
and I think if you do those
micro goals on a daily basis,
it doesn't lead to these oh shit moments
where you wake up and you've been doing
the same thing for five years
and you're unhappy. Right?
You need to start taking that into your
own hands on daily basis and really
evaluating what are some of your goals
right now from a business standpoint?
I mean, I just think that's service based.
Fitness is a way to go. I really do.
I feel very passionate about it. I think
that you would say, what does that mean?
You just service like you walk into a gym.
I want to be,
so once the want to help me, I want
their guidance and direction. You know,
think about hotels. You go into a hotel,
gym, the four seasons everywhere else.
It's like, hello sir, how can I help
you? This that you're going to the gym,
there's no one there.
You just get on the elliptical and you
have an aimless workout. No direction,
no guidance.
So from a business perspective,
I want to bring service to the hotels.
I want to bring service to corporate
wellness where instead of people is going
to the gym and you know,
wearing their headphones.
Now all of a sudden they're creating
connections and that helps with
productivity in the workplace.
It creates with foster and his sense of,
of more culture in that workplace
and then also wanting to that on the
commercial side,
open to the public.
I want to be experts in the best
at service based fitness, right.
Bringing the highest level of of of
quality coaching combined with quality
programming in a fun atmosphere. That's
what we're really focused on right now.
This then, if we could rewind the clock,
this is from Pilar Eggman think it is.
If you, I mean it's Jason could go back
to 2008 after winning the crossfit games,
what advice would you give yourself in
regards for training for the Games and or
business? Yeah. What advice would you give
your self at that time?
It doesn't have to be actually related
to games. Business, I'd say, Eh,
what advice period?
The advice I would say is earlier on
identify this whole concept of Mri
mentality and evaluate more regularly
because there's times in my life that I,
that I regret not spending
quality time with. You know,
I mean I don't necessarily regret
cause he's got us where we're at today,
but there's been times where I
haven't been the most present father.
I've been doing a lot different things
and I wish I had learned that earlier on.
At least now when I
travel or like the small,
I left the house at four and I'm
not going to be home until later.
At least now every time I do that I
recognize that it's a sacrifice I'm making
but that I have to except
it and then you know,
try and make it right in the future.
Right.
But at least being aware
that there's sacrifice.
I think before it was just kinda
like I was trying to just do so much.
Now I need to identify and say no to
more things so I could really start
pinpointing my focus.
The question I had earlier about how
you go about doing that is still one I'd
like to dig into a little bit cause I
think it's so important. For instance,
I was chatting a few months
ago with this older gent.
He's in his sixties he has a couple of a
bunch of kids and every quarter he gets
a report card from his wife and the
report card is a zero to 10 in four
categories. He's got
provider, husband, father,
lover. Those are the
four. Wow. And he for,
he owns his own company,
at least one company and travels a lot.
So let's say he's traveling,
but it's for business purposes and he's
opening up new manufacturing plants or
whatever it might be in China. Who
knows? So he's gone. So he'll get,
he might get a 10 out of 10 and provider,
but he's going to probably be very low on
the lover score and so on and so forth.
You know,
may five out of six on the others who
knows and it's allowable as long as he has
a good average.
So it's like one can drop as long as
the others are higher and so on it,
how do you keep track
of reprioritizing or,
or think about that?
Is it,
is it all in the head or do you put it
down anywhere or is it something that you
try to do at the end of each work day?
I know we talked about it a little bit.
Yeah, I think it's just in
my head. I think it's just
constant evaluation whether,
um, um, you know, I like to,
let's just say, you know,
be alone with my thoughts and like in
the garage working out and I just think
about, you know, hey, what am I doing
right now? What am I doing well,
what can we do better at? How can I be
better at this, this, this, this, this,
and it's just that constant pursuit
of being better at whatever I'm doing.
And I think it's an internal
conversation with myself.
And I think that if I ever
get complacent or comfortable,
that's where I start getting nervous.
And I think I want to get
uncomfortable in business.
I want to get uncomfortable and get out
there and start sharing my message of
what I'm trying to do and what we're
trying to accomplish and provide for more
people to do what they love for a living.
And these are the conversations
I have in my head, right, is hey,
eva is getting better now. I can start
focusing a little bit more on this,
but don't forget about this,
you know, and things like that.
Do you have any favorite books or books
that you've gifted to other people?
Either or both. The one that stands
out to me the most. I read a lot.
I think there's some really poor books
at the airport. I really do. Sure.
Anyways, for me, I like more
of a Pratt publication book.
I like a book like Mark
Cuban's sportive business.
I like it because it gets me fired up.
I like it cause it's a real story from
a real guy just saying like it is and
it's easy reading. It's not so
analytical and things like that. And uh,
so that's the look I like.
Got It.
Let's talk about morning rituals if you
have any. So this is from dot. S G no.
Or Sj,
excuse me.
What are some morning rituals
or reflections that he
does to keep passion alive
while juggling children and
life's twists and turns?
So I would say let's focus on the, on the
routines or rituals. Like do you have,
do you have any, if we look at
the first 90 minutes of your day,
and I'm sure it varies, but generally
speaking, are there certain routines,
habits,
elements that you have?
I'd say in general it's probably
some type of exercise in general.
There's exceptions to that, right?
But in general it's exercise,
whether it be Jujitsu or you know,
hitting it in my garage, whatever it is.
I like to get the body moving and I like
to get flowing early in the morning.
Do you do that before breakfast? After
breakfast. Before, before breakfast.
So that's before the kids get up.
That's before my wife is up
as before everything that,
what time is that typically would
you say? I mean it varies. You know,
used to be a lot earlier.
Now it's like, I mean,
well this morning I left
early yesterday I left early,
but on average it's probably
six, six. Yeah, because some
days it's a lot earlier.
Sundays is seven. And you're
exercising on an empty stomach. Yeah.
Did you drink coffee? I do. I love coffee.
Do you drink coffee before your workout?
Would you say that for later?
How many cups of coffee do you have a
day? Um, I probably have one and a half.
Okay. To maybe modern.
Maybe. I love coffee. Um,
what I'll do is normally exercise, come
in, see the kids. I'll make my coffee,
like doing pour overs. I want to
get a really cool espresso machine.
That's what I'm working on next. Um,
and you know, hanging out with the kids,
they get breakfast, boom, they go off
to school and I go off to work and uh,
we do our thing and then
I'll be there and I'll, you,
I'll go to meetings or
go to different gyms.
I'll try and just see what's going on.
Then sometimes I'll do, uh, you know,
workout. I'll take one of
our classes right throughout
the bay area. And then, um,
I'm always home for dinner
at five 30 with the family.
And then I get back on emails and
different stuff around seven, eight, uh,
around seven 30 till about 10 when
the key, because the kids go to sleep.
So basically his regiment, my day is
like, it's exercise, get the body moving,
it's time with the family briefly in the
morning, they go to school, I go to work.
Then when I get home at five
30, we have dinner, we hang out.
Then for the rest of the night
I'm doing work and I go to bed.
I check my bed by 10 30, 10, 10,
30, and then do it all over again.
Do you have any particular,
and maybe this doesn't happen to you,
but when you have so many different hats,
right?
I mean you have your business
owner, father, husband, uh,
certainly competitor make,
perhaps not going into
the games necessarily,
but still you have extreme athletic drive.
Do you have insomnia or do
you find it easy to sleep?
Do you ever have insomnia or you, so I
find it pretty easy to sleep, you know,
you'd think with, with the different
stresses I have, uh, I, no,
I think it's because I exhaust
myself throughout the day. Right.
I generally run it a high, like some
people say it's like the, the um,
full throttle or like,
you know,
like I generally run on a high level
throughout the duration of the day.
Kind of like a kid,
you know,
it's like [inaudible] and then all
of a sudden they get to you like,
like a bedtime.
It's like you just don't happen to me.
You definitely have a
sort of high standard Rpm,
which is good.
Do you have any wind down routines or
anything you'd like to do before bed?
I mean,
generally it's,
it's answering a lot of emails because
during the day I'm doing a lot of other
stuff is dancing, a lot of
emails, getting back to people.
And then sometimes my wife and I,
we'll watch a show together.
But that's pretty much it. That's it.
And then Facebook and then face plant.
And on the weekends I'm like,
you know, we like to travel,
we like to go do things like last
weekend or this week can come up,
we're going to Disneyland
with my daughter. And uh,
that weekend after we're going to Mexico
to see one of our locations balls have
a good time. So we try and travel
as a family and have those times.
Who Do you go to for business advice?
And I got a few. I mean, you know,
we have a few mentors have really helped
out some of our corporate partners.
Western digital is one of them.
Some executives in there have really
been amazingly helpful just in asking you
about things. Because for me and my
industry, sometimes I get overwhelmed.
So I need to get outside. My industries
are asking what's going on. And you know,
I have also friends through different
sponsorships that I have that they really
helped me out from, you know,
Paul and I have a lot of people.
And then in the beginning,
who would they? Paul Gomez.
It's got my core Donohoe
Jerry. Um, and then Joe Jagan
Tino back in the day. Right.
Was like the original guy that really
kind of took me under his wings from a
business perspective.
And then this guy,
men taught me everything to do with
sales. Okay. So wait, so as Joe,
the fellow on the elliptical. Yup. Josie,
elliptical and men was guy who
came over on a ship from Vietnam,
got in a concentration camp in uh,
I want to say like career something and
ended up getting here selling perfume
door to door. And now he's doing really
well for himself. So straight up hustling.
How did you meet men?
He was the gym sales guy and I wanted
to be like him because he was making big
checks.
So you met him at the same time that you
were also later doing the elliptical?
Yeah, mentoring sessions
happening. How ambushing him.
I was working the front desk and so
men would put in his sales slips and I
looked at his commission slips and
I was like, dude, what's going on?
Teach me how to sell.
And he did.
And that was really a cool experience
because I learned at a talk to different
people, identify what their wants
and needs were and you know,
see what's going on.
But it was also a time of my life where
I started recognize that you need to run
an ethical business just
because you make money.
Making money is not everything in life.
Running a very ethical,
successful businesses critical for me.
And what would happen is I would
sell them the dream like, Hey,
join our gym for nine, nine
nine a month. And you know,
you're getting the best shape
of your life, but they wouldn't.
And I knew I was selling
them a false hope.
And so that's when I got into the kind
of like the Group, uh, coaching style,
which just changed the game for me. I want
to talk about two, two pieces of that.
What made been so good at selling?
I mean,
the best way to describe him as a
straight up hustler. I mean just,
just hustling like right.
But for some people that's going to
conjure the image of like some guy with a
foldout table and three card Monte.
He was like picks up and runs away
from the cops when the siren, sorry.
He lived by the code, you
know, abcs always be closing.
Huges identify what someone needed to
hear and he would work really hard at
doing it and there was no sugarcoating.
He would follow up with people.
You would tour people.
Well he showed me from an early age
that there's no easy answer in life.
You've got to put in the work and you've
got to get on the phones and hustle it
and you want to,
you want to get leads,
go to the collections who like
all the members who are past due,
call them all and try and collect it.
Go back to people who visited the gym
from five years. Go and call them.
And I would just end it with stacks, be
on the phone that Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. You got, maybe you
get one. What's the, uh, so what,
what would be an example of say and a
potentially successful script or question
when you're,
when you're calling up the Glengarry
leads that you have from five years ago,
what, what, what does a good call
look like if you were you, if you,
if someone in your company had
that job today and you're like,
here's a stack that have starts smiling
and dialing, what would you tell them?
I mean, I think you start off
just saying, Hey, I'm, you know,
I'm Jason [inaudible] with NC fit. Uh,
I just want to follow up with your,
you know, whatever. Um, I
think really what you would
try and do is just identify,
hey, so you know, you know, how has
your experience, we're just checking up.
Did you enjoy your experience? What were
you looking for out of your experience?
And you identify with they're looking
for, right? And they say, Oh, well,
did you hear that? We actually
just added program that, you know,
kind of tailors to what
they were looking for.
And I think finding out
what people are looking for,
I think it's really important.
Instead of trying to force
feed what you think they want,
find out what they do want. Asking
good questions. What's, what's,
what are the magic ingredients to a good
tour? He said men toward, well, oh man,
he had toward the best,
you know, you know,
to some people just be treadmills
and ellipticals, but to him it was,
it was money making pieces of
machinery that you could sell. Hey,
this is the,
you know,
lifestyle 10 32 top of its class.
It comes to the fan. It
seems music to you, right?
And you just like selling a Mercedes
and then you'd talk about the treadmill.
You talk about this and that. Oh by the
way, let me show you downstairs. Did we,
you know, and then finally get
down to the DA. And it's like, oh,
did we tell you though that you could,
for an additional $8 a month,
you can get teleservice and let
me show you where those towels go.
Let me show you what they look like and
let me show you the quality of them.
Right. And those are the types
of things that you learn, right?
It's just if you have a, did he have
a strong accent or no. Oh yeah. No,
that's great though because it just
shows you like it does not matter.
You're very strong views. No,
nobody powered through it. I mean,
I used to live in San Jose
and, and uh, you know,
used to go to a Vietnamese
barbershop and it's,
it's one of my best friends growing up was
Vietnamese on long island. And I, when,
when anyone has a strong accent,
it's a heart. It's a strong accent.
But he was able despite that to just
power through and become one of the top,
if not the top. Oh, it was, he was a
dude. Oh yeah, he was, he was a baller.
I learned a lot from him.
All right.
I'm going to ask just a few more questions
and then maybe we can do around two
sometimes since we're basically in
the same, same neighborhood. Uh,
one would be if you could put
any message on a billboard,
and this is a metaphor really,
but just to get a message
out to millions of people,
let's assume it's noncommercial,
right? So it can't be an advertisement,
but what might you put on a billboard?
I mean I would,
I would love to get this out to as many
people as you could possibly push us too.
It would just say like be easy.
It's like life is good.
And I mean that because I really believe
that meaning when you seen children,
you know, when you seen
children, oncology,
it changes your whole perspective.
Yesterday I was on the road and this
woman is just tailing me so hard coming
around, get all crazy. I just look
over at her. I'm just like easy, easy,
like life is good.
You have a beautiful car,
you look healthy and young
and pretty whatever. Like
chill the hell out. You know?
And I think people,
they get so caught up in these little
problems and he let it manifest into
something so great that they stopped to,
they never stopped reflect that,
hey look, life is okay. But I,
I choose to look at the world.
Me Personally, I choose, look at the world
in a pair of glasses, not sunglasses.
I choose to look at things in a brighter
light because especially after you,
I spent three nights in the ICU and I,
my daughter was on the brink of not good.
You know,
you don't go to the ICU as a cancer
patient. I mean it was really,
really not good.
Right.
It was the only time that we really felt
like it was a life and death situation.
I'm sitting there and there's this baby
to my left and he's seven months old and
his dad comes in.
The baby had never left the ICU before
and all night they were there were
sucking fluid out of this
kid's lung because he had
pneumonia or whatever it was.
And I'm sitting there for
two days straight, right up
all night eating muffins,
looking at my daughter over here,
like really not in good shape.
And this guy or this baby over here in
the dead, I'm just sitting there like,
and people are complaining that there's
traffic and fucking plane and it's just,
no, I'm not expecting people. I never want
anybody to be in our position. I don't.
But what I want you to do is to really
reflect on their life and realize that
everybody has something to be grateful
for. If you think about it, right,
you're alive,
you're well,
you have the ability to get up and go do
some amazing things, you know? And, uh, I,
I think that sometimes people get
caught up and they forget that.
I think they could use a reminder of that.
Yes. I think that is where, shoot,
we should wrap up. That is, uh,
I think that is if among many other
things, what I want people to remember.
So that's a, that's a fantastic
point. And just in closing,
where can people find you online,
learn more about you,
learn more about your
business and, and, and
anything else you'd like them
to take a look at? Yeah, I
mean, I, uh, NC fit right?
nc.fit would be great. Um, I'm very
active on Instagram. Jason Cleave, uh, um,
I don't use Facebook as much.
I probably should. In Twitter,
I leave a k, h, k, h, a, l.
I, p, h. And. M. You know, I do
these things called box of business.
There's seminars we do for
affiliate owners or, or gym owners.
My partner and I had JP. We do, I'm all
for charity and pediatric cancer. And so,
you know, back to one of the questions,
we have a blood drive cut up in September.
We do that on a nationwide scale at
different crossfit gyms around the world,
just to place it since people who might
be listening five years from now as it's
2017. Okay, good. We're gonna do it on a
yearly basis. Oh, you are? Okay. Go. Yeah.
Right. But at, at the end of the day,
um, yeah, you could just find me NC.
Dot Fit Jason cleveland.com
or Jason Clip on Instagram.
You can find a lot of stuff about,
about,
yeah, that awesome. Well guys,
say hello to Jason and uh, it's,
it's great to meet you, man. It's been
a long time coming. I mean, I've, uh,
I've followed your career for a while now,
so it's,
it's really nice to meet in person and
thanks Mark Bell, Mr Smelly himself,
Mr thousand pound back squat for
making the introduction. And uh,
so first and foremost, uh, I should
say thank you for taking the time.
I appreciate you making it, making
the time today. Oh, thank you.
Thanks for having me. Yeah, man. A really
fun and there's so much more to dig into,
so,
uh,
hopefully folks will be able to do around
too and get more questions answered.
And if you want to see
some additional video,
make sure you go to tim.blog/podcast
where you can find show notes for this
episode, links to everything, books and
so on. I mentioned, uh, links to Jason,
his sites and so on,
as well as some
demos and work in the gym
that we recorded earlier.
So you can find that at
tim.blog/podcast and as always,
until next time, thank you for
listening. Hey guys, this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before
you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll
get the very next one and if you sign
up, I hope you enjoy it. This episode
is brought to you by legal zoom.
I have used legal zoom myself for many
of my businesses and many of the icons on
this podcast. I've actually
used legal zoom, for instance,
Matt Mullenweg of Wordpress,
feigns CEO of Automattic,
which is now worth more than a billion
dollars first incorporated his company on
legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that
more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses.
Whether that's setting up a will,
doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit or finding simple
cease and desist letter templates.
Man do I use a lot of those?
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they do have a network of independent
attorneys available in most states.
They can give you advice on
the best way to get started,
provide contract reviews and otherwise
help you run your business and important,
there are no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency.
That means upfront pricing, customer
reviews, and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout Legal zoom.com today to see
how they can make life better and easier
for you and your business. If you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the Internet,
then you are asking for trouble.
Put together the safety nets.
Get your t's crossed and your I's dotted.
Enter Promo Code Tim tim@legalzoom.com
to save 15% that's t I m for 15% off.
Check it out legal zoom.com this
episode is brought to you by ink.
Tell use them personally. Ever since
I wrote the four hour work week,
I've been asked over and over again
how I choose to delegate tasks,
how I do 80 20 analysis and so on.
At the root of many of those decisions
is a simple question. Actually.
Two questions. Number one,
how can I invest money to
improve my quality of life?
I use that in investing as well.
The how can I spend a little money or
moderate money to save significant time
inc tell is one of those investments.
They're a turnkey solution for all of
your imaginable customer care needs.
I used eight tell during the launch
of the four hour body which was very,
very involved and they provided 24
seven customer service for my land rush
campaign because it was critical for
me to take care of every person who
purchased my books and participating in
this allowed me to focus on the things
that I am better at.
My strengths like the marketing plan
that we'd worked on for six months,
implementing that until
trains their experience.
Customer service reps to
know your business and your
products inside and out and
make your customers raving fans.
They answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they
can do so across all platforms including
email, phone, social media, text.
You can chat leaving your customers with
whore service or just mediocre service,
which by the way,
in a competitive pool is a huge liability.
Long wait times are unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business.
Uh,
Intel removes the logistics and
headaches of this type of communication,
allowing you to focus on your
strengths and grow your business.
It can be a real competitive advantage.
And I see many,
many ecommerce companies
and tech companies thinking
of customer service as a
good enough checkbox or an afterthought,
and it just like airbnb use design and
innovative ways to be a competitor and to
win that. You can do the same
thing with customer service.
So as a listener of this podcast,
you can get up to $10,000
off with this gun,
$10,000 off your startup fees and costs
by visiting [inaudible] dot com forward
slash 10 so check it out. For
more info, go to [inaudible],
tell.com I N K t e
l.com forward slash Tim.